for now Africa has been spared by a
major outbreak of the disease so far
they have been just 12 confirmed cases
that's in Egypt Tunisia Algeria Morocco
Nigeria and Senegal but is this because
the disease has not spread or because it
has not been detected that's the
billion-dollar question the World Health
Organization has warned that countries
with poor healthcare systems may not be
able to cope with an outbreak with many
in Africa being of particular concern
screening has been introduced at most
major African airports and border
crossings they're using mechanisms
already established during the Ebola
outbreak in West Africa from 2014 to
2016 when it comes to the new
coronavirus health officials know early
detection is vital if an epidemic is to
be avoided so as we talked in Uganda we
still don't have anybody with foreigner
virus in Senegal which has so far
reported two confirmed cases people are
buying up sanitizers and masks some
pharmacists say they're running short
already even though it doesn't look too
serious for now seems to be increasing
Airlines from many African countries
have suspended flights to and from China
now Kenya has also canceled flights to
and from northern Italy testing
facilities on the continent have been
increased meaning by now most countries
are able to test the capacity of
countries to address this outbreak has
improved extremely in the last few
months while we've been working with
countries however as medical workers
across major cities are preparing
isolation wards at hospitals their
concern remains most African health care
systems do not have the capacity to deal
with a la
scale outbreak of coronavirus now let's
go have a quick chat with dr. Mary
Stefan with the weg regional office for
Africa in Brazzaville Republic of Congo
hello dr. Mary many thanks for your time
now Africa has recorded very few cases
but the international community is
worried why okay so as you are aware the
outbreak started in China and it has
spread to different countries and of
course Africa is also at risk because of
the volume of travelers between Africa
and all the affected areas so the
likelihood that there would be
importation of cases into Africa is very
high and they might also be worried
because of the fragility of the systems
in Africa and also the population we
have in Africa but just where we assure
the world that we are enhancing our
level of preparedness in Africa so we
can detect the cases and also respond
appropriately okay
now still about 14 African countries do
not have testing equipment for
coronavirus that obviously is a
challenge how prepared are we you are
right so we have right now 34 countries
that have the capacity to test and there
were many countries we are helping them
to prepare and enhance their capacity to
confirm cope with 19 but for those that
do not currently have the capacity for
testing we are encouraging them to send
if they have a suspected case to send in
their samples to their neighboring
countries and also they can send samples
to the reference laboratories in South
Africa and institut pasteur in dhaka so
in terms of preparedness at the
beginning of the outbreak we have
assessed the capacities of all the 47
countries that fall under the doublet
regional office for Africa so
we pretty much know the capacities that
the countries have and we are helping
them to enhance capacities in places
where they have some weaknesses so we
have already deployed experts to some of
these countries and they are helping
them we will repeat the assessment again
to see how far they have progressed in
terms of okay okay now let's get a bit
practical here a lot of people are
panicking we see that all the time
people are wearing face marks here and
there hand sanitizers have run out so so
give us three major points for
individuals how they can prevent
themselves from contacting the virus to
prevent oneself from contacting
coronavirus first of all we talk about
social distancing so you stay one to two
metres away and also regular hand
washing with soap and water
or we use hand sanitizers to make sure
that our hands are clean and also if one
is coughing add appropriate use of
coughing etiquette so cover your nose
with tissue and properly dispose it
afterwards or use the elbow to cough so
that we prevent spread of aerosols to
people that are sitting around us okay
I'll tell you what I'm going to wash my
hands and use the hand sanitizer right
after this interview is that okay okay
thank you very much dr. Mary Stephen
with the WH original office for Africa
in Brazzaville many thanks for your time